this is a production of Cornell
University so this is gonna be a little
bit different from the more usual
hundred percent research seminar as you
can hear from our affiliations so this
is a combination of research especially
the first section that I'm presenting
and then extending into a conversation
so we want to invite you all to join a
conversation that the three of us have
been having for a couple of years about
exactly this topic so along those lines
I'd like to invite you to jump in get
your hand up interrupt with a question
or correction or an observation or if
we're using some jargon that you're not
sure about so so please chime in it at
any time so for part one I'm gonna cover
all these topics but fairly quickly so
trying to talk about what do we mean by
idle lands and it's a little trickier
than you might think and then another
term is marginal lands doing the same
applies to that so the research portion
that we did was looking at what land
might be available that's not currently
in in any type of commercial production
and how much hay and forage could be
produced on that and the research part
that I'm talking about is assuming a
high intensity management on that so
kind of what's the technical high end
potential for for production and that's
I should say that's not typical for a
lot of land in New York it's not managed
at that high intensity and then some
some very broad estimates of what could
we produce on these lands how much beef
could we produce how much bioenergy
feedstock and bio energy could we
produce and how much hay and forage
could we produce and then then Mike and
Aaron are going to jump in with some
reality checks
on this kind of technical potential and
say what are some of the challenges and
barriers that are in the way of
achieving this technical potential so
here's a nice photo courtesy of Mike so
what are we talking about with idle
lands marginal lands what's this all
about
so typically if you're driving around
New York State you often see the bottom
land which often is in it can be an
annual crop production if you can see
the hay bales here there's hay
production on some of the sloping land
and then the further up you get this all
this shrub land could be pasture could
be who knows what could be transitioning
slowly back into forest so what we mean
by idle lands for especially my portion
of the talk is it as I mentioned it's
not currently in you know commercial
production but it's really a wide
variety of land cover so it could be
more or less kind of look like hay or
pasture it might look more like shrub
scrubland it's not a forest and it's not
annual cropland but there's a there's a
lot of territory in between there and
it's hard to quantify this because it's
something that's not really counted
right it's the agricultural survey gives
us the land that's in production there's
an older separate survey of horses in
new york estimating they use about a
million acres of land some of that's on
farms and much of it is not but beyond
that we have very little survey data
about how the land this these lands are
being used so an important thing here is
when we say idle that really should have
quotation marks around it because it
could be used for hunting it could be
used for some non-commercial use
so we we can't say that the land isn't
being used for anything you just know
it's not in commercial production
okay marginal lands I love this quote
I'll give you a chance to read it I
think it sums it up very nicely
so the gist of it is we use this loosely
for land that has biophysical problems
and if you notice this quotes from 1932
but this kind of sloppy thinking and
talk about marginality is is still
happening well I think that the real
definition is economic so its marginal
for some type of economic production
meaning there's little or no possibility
of a profit so on good soils as you
increase inputs like fertiliser and
labour you get a pretty big jump in your
return in production on marginal soils
you could put in the same amount of
effort and inputs but you get a much
lower plateau of production and if these
are the production costs
on the prime soils you've got lots of
room for profitability and on the
marginal soils little or none right so
that's that's to me what marginal really
means
so what why is it marginal so this is
where we get back to the biophysical
part often wet stony perched water
tables etc and you all may have your
your favorite issues of what kind of
limitations occur on some lands in New
York so an important thing I said is so
so some marginal crop lanes are now
wineries so they might be marginal for
beef production or for hay production
they might be great for wineries so it
marginality is an economic term and it's
related to what the heck you're
producing right it's not the same for
everything
so how did we go about with all those
challenges kind of estimate how much
idle land there is so we start with
spatial data to look at land cover
through the state and that helps us
narrow down and get rid of the forests
and get rid of the annual cropland and
the developed land but then we use AG
survey data to tell us at the county
scale how much land is in commercial
production
so our result I'm not going to go into a
lot of detail about methods here is just
under a million hectares or 689 thousand
hectares of potentially idle potentially
available land so here's a picture of
land cover for all of New York State
lots of forests fair amount of wetlands
and developed land about 9% in annual
cropland about 9% in grasslands that are
in production of some kind and then this
is what we came up with that about 5% of
New York State is idle grasslands about
3% is idle shrub and scrub lands so
meaning what's what's there now so these
are the I mentioned the total but it's
not all all this land may not be
suitable or as I mentioned before it's
not necessarily all really available
that's what people want to do with their
land so how do we then estimate
production potential on these marginal
lands and we use a combination of soil
properties and climate and that's
integrated into something called the
national commodity crop productivity
index so this is just a map showing this
index with the low values in red the
high values in green you don't see much
green the better AG lands in New York
are showing up in the mid range of
yellow here
and see this in Ohio there's there's
some patches of green there so where do
we see a lot of these low productivity
or low soil quality lands Adirondacks
Catskills and then some of the southern
tier as well so this is then the this
available potentially available I'll
land shown across this soil quality
index so the index goes from 0 to 1 so
the high values are good so for current
hail and we see most of its kind of in
this mid range meaning it's not all that
different really from a lot of our
annual cropland
the land that's currently in herbaceous
cover of some kind
again most of its in kind of this this
middle range a shrub and scrubland more
of it is in this lower productivity
range but the important thing is it's
really all of these are pretty well
spread out so within any of these
categories there are some soils that
have some heist biophysical soil quality
but that's encouraging if we can find
those and use them so to to model
potential hay and forage production on
these lands we have a very simple
generic model of productivity potential
for for essentially perennial grasses
and we have we created separate ones for
warm season grasses meaning c4 and cool
season grasses meaning c3
so again this result is a technical
potential assuming a high intensity of
management and again that's not typical
but it's but it's possible
then we have valuated these models by by
looking at how do these models do with
some data that we did not use to develop
the models from forage yield trials
throughout New York State sorry this
this is a photo of a yield trial
courtesy of Julie Hanson who works very
hard with the team on conducting these
trials for many years so the three lines
are models I'm not going to talk about
corn silage today but just to point out
that it's the model and the data are
higher for corn silage than for any of
these perennials
and for the cool-season grasses there's
there's a range among sites in years but
the data from these yield trials seem to
suggest that our our simple models
aren't too far wrong meaning that the
the data are falling reasonably close to
our predictions that were again
independent of these data just a quick
note on why are the warm season grasses
lower productivity than the cool season
grasses and and this is just a really a
function of the effort that's gone into
breeding and managing cool season
grasses in the state so with a great
deal of effort and over many years or
decades there's no reason why the warm
season grasses couldn't move up further
but this is what we think is feasible
today so an example of a warm season
grasses switchgrass I'm not going to try
to read the whole slide but this was
kind of our model grass for thinking
about bioenergy production or the for
the forage we were looking more at the
cool season grasses but we also
translated essentially our effort was on
what's the forage production potential
and then we just used a simple very
crude calculation to say a certain
number of pounds of forage in a beef
stocker operation meaning beef foraging
throughout the growing season you know
how many pounds of forage would
translate into a pound or a kilogram of
beef and we've done a lot of work
historically on bioenergy so we also
looked at again the warm season grass is
turning those into industrial quality
pellets and using them for heat
and and also for ethanol so these are
our results and this is just a summary
for the entire state so the very small
bars are beef because we're looking at
total millions of kilograms per year on
all of this idle land base so so beef
production is is very low in terms of
kilograms or terms of millions of
kilograms and then the highest
production potential is the hay so
essentially with the with the pellets
we're losing some through the process of
manufacturing them and they're also
being made from the c4 grass which
according to our modeling is a likely be
a little less productive if we look at
these in terms of the value of that
product not profit but just the value of
that production at the wholesale level
not to surprisingly all these bars
switch direction right so that's all
amount of beef production has the
highest dollar value actually all these
other options haven't had a similar
roughly similar sorry dollar dollar
value so here are a few challenges and
barriers what are the landowners goals
are you in a location where it's
feasible to actually use this land do
you need fencing do you need drainage do
you need barns its capital available
even if it's a viable business model etc
and my kin and Erin are gonna talk about
a little more about some of these and I
hope you'll all think and chime in if
you think of other challenges and
barriers and of course opportunities as
well
so summarizing 4.1 there's there's quite
a bit of land out there that's not in
commercial production and some some
fraction of that could be available for
increased production and some fraction
of those lands actually have decent
biophysical soil properties so there's a
technical potential with high-intensity
management to produce quite a bit on
these lands but of course there are a
lot of challenges and barriers that mean
it's not able to achieve all of that
technical potential I have a few
citations that will come up at the at
the end of the talk and I haven't really
it looks like we could take a few
questions right now before we move into
the second part if anyone has anything
right now
Peter go hear him yes genius a lot of
margins may not be continuous but in
order to have cows or to produce there
is a little bit we we removed pieces of
land that were that were less than five
hectares I believe so we were trying to
get rid of those small pieces of land
that would be hard to to bring into
production Peter did you look at all
into why these lands are not being used
now I mean we'll see the constraints
later on but I mean did anyone know or
is anyone looked at why is it I don't
know okay essentially we have no we're
doing everything by difference right
identifying the idle land because it's
not something else so we know almost
nothing about it I mean it could be
because there's not enough labor in the
earth or there's other aspect I mean
what are the reasons that no one is
using it now interesting yeah I think
you know all we can say about that is
the slide I showed of sort of a
histogram of the soil quality showing
that in fact quite a large portion of
these lands are of reasonable production
potential according to this that's why I
asked the question yeah thank you but I
mean so another clue you can look at is
landowner surveys and most many
landowners are not interested in
commercial production of any kind so
that's another quick answer right and as
lands change hands they tend to be
moving out of farmer hands and into
other landowner hands so that's another
trend that there's some data about
either a good question of you come
across what you know what is the
intrinsic value of these lands I mean
they're marginal but they could have
other you know conservation those
externalities do they come into play I
mean I realize for production but this
might be an argument that somebody might
said what's wrong with having described
her life you don't know yeah so I think
I would so i yes these lands have lots
of value for lots of things hunting you
know there's some endangered there's
some least threatened bird species that
nest in grasslands so some some operate
like switchgrass production is
compatible with spring breeding birds
because you just harvest in the fall too
baby
but but yes there are competing current
uses that are non commercial there are
other values to these lands so that's
why sort of the Idol is in quotation
marks yeah riff on something that David
was saying and I think Accenture sort of
selling yourself short on the idle land
question because I would perceive that
the idle land of today is going to
become forested land of tomorrow and so
I'm wondering if maybe you should sort
of think that some of the forested land
of today was in fact idle land of
yesterday and so I'm wondering if the
acreage that you're looking at may be
actually an underestimate and denied yes
there has been a Greek ultra land that
has transitioned back to forests so so
depending on the location and what's
going on and seed sources for the forest
and deer pressure etc it can take a
surprisingly long time you know decades
or more or never to get back to sort of
an intact valuable forest there's a very
long period of time and it may be kind
of indefinite that it can be in this
shrub scrub you know Hawthorn I'm sure
we've all walked through this kind of
land
I don't know if that answers it at all
no I am just thinking from from a land
potential obviously you have today the
scent is clear to put it back kind of
land but you know it's in a potential
Weiser I would think that there'd be a
lot more land available that would fit
into this model
sure right so intentionally we did not
look at forest land and we did not look
at wetlands both of those potentially
could be brought into production but our
thinking is there's a lot more conflicts
with that and it's also a lot more
effort and challenge to actually achieve
that so that's why we focus on the lands
that are not forest not wetlands great
well let's move on to to Mike and and
part two deal I've just add a few
comments to that if we think about what
this plan was used for 50 years ago it
was in dairies so what has changed as
these dairies have moved as a dairy
structure has changed even though that
land may be productive it's as one
person mentioned here they're in smaller
acreage is harder to use with larger
equipment and so these dairies have gone
to land more suitable for crop
production so that's that's a big part
especially in southern tier why there's
so much Idol playing in that area and
the other thing I would argue is that we
want open land for aesthetic reasons we
don't want to look like New Hampshire at
least I don't where it's all trees and
so I think very strong argument is is to
keep open land all right so when we look
at the I like this slide because when we
look at whether a business can be
profitable or not it's based on what
their local resources are in making the
Bessy so so they
a logger in Maine was smart enough to
know that he's well-endowed with with
moose in the area and so he used him to
to move his logs I've never been able to
confirm or deny whether this is
photoshopped or real alright so you know
we all know this we're in the pasture
region right forage reason we can grow
forages extremely well we're not in the
Corn Belt region
so growing corn really doesn't fit our
environment and so consequently we need
to again if we're going to have
profitable agricultural businesses we
need to focus on what we have lots of
and that's forage this is a picture this
is just some data from the southern tier
of vacant land that the doctor if put
together for me
this is Steuben County there was a
glitch in the data collection Lester
been isn't that would fit in very well
with all the other counties and that you
can see very visually there's a lot of
vacant land in this southern tier area
and if she had done the the northern New
York area and actually even some of that
central New York is the same way so what
are the resources that we have in in New
York to make beef cattle work
we've got markets the and a whole
variety markets in terms of
grass-finished organic GMO free free
range but we also do have some grain
finished markets natural is growing
quite often which is often grain
finished but no use of growth furrow d
hormones or antibiotics so because of
the consumer demand those are resources
that we can take advantage of and the
reason for that is is consumers you know
Montana has an advantage where they have
lots of cows but they don't have any
consumers and so
that gives us lots of opportunity to to
diversify our portfolio if you will and
meet that demand so one of the
advantages and I'm going to talk
specifically about this stalker that was
mentioned that's the N it's a youngish
animal that's put on grass grazes for
the summer and then goes into a
finishing program which can be
historically grain finish but also can
go into a grass finish system so it's
that short period of time from made of
October Titan so it's one of the few
enterprises AG enterprises that you can
get into with very little capital
upfront if you're going to try to start
a dairy it's nearly impossible unless
you and marry into it or inherit it so
that provides a huge advantage a cost of
production is low here in the Northeast
our calves are cheap much to the
disgruntlement of our cow-calf producers
but there's reasons for that which we
talk about another time
we've got relatively good production per
acre in terms of forage and that's
extremely important for ruminants those
that can take that we have inexpensive
land I know a lot of people don't
believe that but I came from West
Virginia and believe it or not land in
West Virginia is more expensive than
here in New York and and you go out and
the corn States
forget it believe it or not for full
time farmers we have a relatively
favorable tax environment because if you
get more than 50 percent of your gross
income from agriculture your taxes are
greatly reduced in terms of school and
property taxes so the the disgruntlement
with taxes is really not entirely true
with this stocker operation we don't
need much equipment which is why you can
get into it without a lot of money you
don't need much facilities obviously
and by doing custom operations that is
owners of cattle will pay you to graze
them you don't need a lot of capital
upfront for the animal purchase so
there's real good opportunities for
getting yet labor flexibility is a great
thing that's a beauty of all beef cattle
operations is if you're a dairy
operation you're tied to that dairy
twice a day plus but the beef operation
you've got a lot more opportunity I was
talking to a meeting last night and he
was going to be away for three or four
days he just filled the hay feeders over
full and they'd be fine he had someone
check on the cows obviously but he
didn't have to feed them every day and
and with the grazing operation you can
do the same so instead of giving them
two acres like you do every day you know
you've got a schedule that's going to
conflict maybe four or five acres
production goes down a little bit but
it's not gonna really impact
profitability for that short period of
time it can be started as a part-time
enterprise again if you're working off
the farm a way to get into the business
and it can be incorporated with other
interests such as Agri Forestry maple
syrup production in the winter those
kinds of things you can and should
probably utilize purchase feeds for
anything you do on most beef operations
and I can argue pretty strongly on that
one even though you see way too much
equipment on beef operations and then
for our current skill force which is
dairy a lot of the skills that they have
and producing high quality forage and
having facilities and equipment can fit
in very nicely with this especially in
the wintertime when we're trying to grow
these calves until they're ready to go
to grass so has a lot of good deal we
can do it with dairy we can do with beef
you can do it with heifers they can do
with cows I mean there are times of the
year where you can buy cows cheap enough
that you can put weight on them
inexpensively on grass and then resell
them so you've got a lot of flexibility
the
thing that's real had been pages to us
is the price cycles if we look at so
that the top line which is the blue line
is over the last 20 years this is the
index of five hundred and fifty pound
feeders you can see in the spring of the
year they're very expensive and or
that's the highest price their lowest in
the fall well look what happens with the
750 pounder which is basically the
result of background our stalker in that
calf it's highest in the fall so you can
buy the calves cheap and put the weight
on by using this cycle and this this is
a pretty strong cycle of not true every
year that nothing is true every year but
it's a pretty consistent historically
system this is the grazing potential and
unfortunately I've not been able to find
any enterprise data past 2014 and ignore
2014 that was a very odd year and those
in the stocker business made a lot of
money but it's not normal but you can
see over the last 10 years or so it's
been about a $70 per head and when you
look at beef enterprises the stocker
operation has more bars above the profit
line than below as compared to cow calf
or finishing so the stalker has a lot of
opportunities the biggest challenge is
that there's not a good market
infrastructure for moving those calves
so we know that the larger the number to
sell the better price we can get which
means that producers need to work
together and any of you that have worked
with farmers knows getting in to work
together is a huge challenge Aaron and I
spent 30 years trying to do it and we'll
retire not getting it done so for the
next generation but cooperation is
something that really needs to happen
and we have a very antiquated if you
will mark auction market system some
states have a very good marketing system
and and so there's just a that market
infrastructure probably is our biggest
drawback to getting this done but
everything else is
all in place pretty nicely leave any
questions that I use any terminology Ken
smiling so I'm waiting for his yep we
that's a great question was had to do
with slaughterhouses and the perceived a
limited number we're just finishing up
another project looking at the barriers
to a ruminant production and north east
and along with that is a survey of
packing plants mostly in new york in new
england and while there is areas of the
state that are I'm talking about
specifically in New York where there are
areas of the state they're short on
Packers it has more to do with
seasonality than it does with supply
because if you look at a small processor
they're really busy from about September
to January and then they're really slow
from then on out
and so Packers and producers need to
work together that terrible word again
to try to even that out Packers need to
charge a little less in the summer
producers need to to match their
production with availability so but
there are some issues sheep could work
to you bet that's not my background but
she certainly there's some predator
challenges and some internal parasite
challenges but you don't have a beef
cattle but yes market was largely cold
consumption
and there's some of that and I think for
to have a large economic impact on with
beef cattle or sheep for that matter
I think assist the system is going to be
both direct sales using smaller plants
as well as some more commodity type
agriculture because I'm you know farmers
do not like the market and so to say the
only way you can do this is to sell
direct to the consumer we're not going
to expand the market I'm a farmer I hate
marketing now ken is a great marketer
and and has built up a business and and
I can point to a lot of farmers that do
that very very well yeah is there
something like crop insurance for beef
production because I see a lot of
variability year to year and you had its
average but there were some years I
would be suffering not for the animal
but there is crop insurance for pasture
and hay land for the actual production
of feed stock there's no the only
subsidy if you will again is based on
the seed feed stock and I will say as
far as the grass-finished market that we
have some organizations now that are
putting into place because I said
farmers don't like to market they like
to produce but I don't like to market so
I think if we had a good steady
year-round market where I could say okay
I've got twenty grass-finished steers
and I know they're gonna be ready and
April and I don't have to worry about
selling them direct I'll take a little
less money but I'll get a premium over
the commodity market and those are
starting to get in place and I think as
I grow we'll see the grain like that
and now there's a feel around but they
struggled so I guess there is there kind
of an opportunity for somebody as a
business proposition and you know maybe
the finishing yeah
I think some coordination would work i
personal opinion but finishing cattle
whether it be on grain or on grass is a
pretty skillful activity and so I think
the way this will work eventually it'd
be most efficient is that we will have
professional grass finishers and then
they will be much easier to fill in
these gaps but the farm with 25 cows and
finishing 10 calves a year just as it's
not gonna work
he or she's never going to gain the
skills to be really good ad to be here
today I would say one reason to keep
land open is because it's an awful lot
of work to clear overgrown land because
they've done it so I'm going to talk
about hay production and again and my
experience we're talking about hilly
rocky clay soil if I were dictator of
the world I would force everyone to have
a garden on hilly rocky clay soil so
they could appreciate good soil and
happy farmers so if you were to go to
the farm newspaper and buy some hay and
look at the classified ads what kind of
hay would you be looking at well how
would it be described
first cutting second cutting alfalfa and
grass and I'm trying to get my farmers
to expand their imagination of hey and
think more about its and new so they can
market it for a target so when we're
when we're selling hay we have local
markets and within the country and we
also have markets outside of the country
which we'll talk about a little bit so
of lay addressing the the horses that
are metabolically challenged they need a
low sugar hey we're grass finishing beef
and sometimes too much protein is not
the way to finish beef we need some high
energy hay some dairy farmers actually
buy straw and stick it in there totally
mixed rations to add a little fiber to
the diet speaking of sheep we have
bird's foot trefoil that can suppress
parasites then we have other you know
animals and different stages of growth
and production that needs specific
nutrients and then also we have our
young livestock that needs something
that's palatable to eat and I have a
particular affinity for Kentucky
bluegrass that I know hey I just think
you know farmers actually call Kentucky
bluegrass dog hair because it's a fine
grass and they don't like it and
sometimes the bales don't hold together
but nutritionally it's actually a pretty
pretty decent pretty decent forage so
has anyone ever heard of Western hay
okay so when farmers think of Western
hay they even in the East here they've
got an image in their head of what
Western hay is it's nice and green
there's no weeds and it's usually pure
grass or pure alfalfa so I guess what I
want to propose is why don't we produce
something why don't we brand New York
hey why don't we think outside the box a
little bit and be a little bit more
creative so my affinity for Kentucky
bluegrass the Dino hey I have a little 1
acre field outside my house that I've
been playing around with and when we
look at some of the
nutrient values of this it's really
quite good in a particular we're looking
at low lignin so in this column if I
went the dairy one and went to their
library this is mixed mostly grass hay
and this is the range of values so when
we look at like lignin you know it's
fairly low in lignin this hay here was
sitting outside for five days before I
finally bailed it because the weather
and machinery so that's the worst of the
law our water soluble carbohydrates are
quite high okay at the high end of the
range this is simple sugars again at the
high end of the range of Grass Hayes
total digestible nutrients you know
we're at the high end again and our in
vitro total digestibility you know looks
pretty good so I think we just need to
get out of our box a little bit and
think about forage a little differently
the other thing is we we have a pretty
difficult environment we have a lot of
humidity out here so sometimes it's hard
to make hay and dry hay so we might need
to add a little technology and so this
is from a machine called a macerator I
don't remember figure out a picture of
it in the next slide or not but it's
basically a roller mill your forage goes
through two steel rollers spinning at
different speeds and you can see how it
scratched the wax off this grass leaf
and that so that helps the hay dry in
good conditions up to a day quicker than
normally and then if you have some old
reed canarygrass the farmer that sells
these was telling me he can take old
reed canarygrass
and run out through his macerator and it
softens it up quite a bit to make it
more palatable
so hey four so that's the domestic
market I think you know we can expand
and be competitive if we can farmers
don't like the market but if we can get
them to market and think about the end
use of their hey maybe they can have
more loyal customers so hey for export
alfalfa Timothy oh hey rye grass straw
when they produce seed out in Oregon and
Washington they take that straw and send
it to Japan for their Wagyu beef
we export grass hay we export straw most
of this is going out from the western
part of the u.s. we had a the National
hay Growers Association meeting here in
in Canandaigua about two years ago and I
attended and met a farmer from
Pennsylvania that actually exports hay
out of the out of Philadelphia so hay
exports of course of late markets have
changed quite a bit
but hey exports do have been increasing
most of them go to Asia but the Middle
East also is buys a lot of our hay
and in fact Saudi Arabia is buying a
bland in Arizona so they can produce
alfalfa because they have a policy where
they don't want to be using their water
and Saudi Arabia for growing alfalfa
because there's better better and higher
uses for it there so they're coming to
our country to produce their hay
so this is just some of this is you know
2017 information here but those are some
of our hay exports and I just figure why
can't we get in here in New York we have
the port of Albany we have us we go and
we have Buffalo why don't we export some
things out of our ports so China was
going to build an alfalfa protein
extraction plant in Canada and this is
some information I read in 2014 I went
back and I don't think they ever came
through with it but as I read it back in
2014 I was thinking you know alfalfa is
50% leaves and 50 prints sent stems you
know why are we why are we shipping
lignin across the ocean it doesn't make
sense and that's why I love Ladino hay
so much is because the way it grows
you're really just harvesting the leaves
and the stems or Stallone's that run
along the ground and if you get a rainy
day a couple rainy days or rainy week
and you can't get to it when you want to
you're not getting the increase in a
neutral detergent fiber that lignin like
you do in alfalfa or grass so it holds
its quality pretty well even in bad
weather
so can we produce a canoe York produce
hay for export
probably not alfalfa the West certainly
has the edge but we can produce Timothy
and mix grass hay we can produce oh hey
and maybe there's some other options rye
grass is also an extra has excellent
forest quality to it so that's something
else we could think about and do we need
to think about some more technology you
know some conditioning machinery or
maybe some inoculants to help us beat
the weather so again the the
transportation part of it so we have the
climate for hay Western companies might
want to spread their risk because out
there they have water issues and I did
talk to a couple of them they haven't
spread their risk by coming out east but
they have considered it
and then we do have a rail system here
in New York that goes throughout the
state different companies own the
different rail lines so I live here in
Washington County and up in Salem
there's a feed plant and you think they
would get their corn by rail from Albany
but actually they don't they have to get
it from East Springfield Massachusetts
so we have a rail system but it's a
little bit tricky and the port of Albany
we take in calcium chloride from Europe
and you know just in the back of my mind
I'm thinking why don't we do a back haul
of hay
maybe some hay cubes and some totes
something they can manage with their
ships
and plus we have two other ports in New
York so the challenges unfortunately I
don't think many you New York farmers
take hey very seriously at the New York
State Fair there was only 18 contestants
that was probably 2017 when I looked it
up we don't really have we don't have a
chapter of the American forage and
grassland council here in New York and I
think that's just indicative of our
attitude towards forage the other I
think this here is probably our biggest
challenge is that many of our acres are
managed by part-time farmers and they're
doing it on the side they're doing it
after work and for them to step up their
game make their business a little bit
more intensive there I don't think
they've got the energy or the interest
to do that they just kind of want to
cruise along
we do have small field sizes and that
does reduce a lot of our efficiency no
matter what even out west and in the
East profit margins are quite tight
weather will always be a challenge to
have consistent quality but that's
something we can we can work with a
little bit and again we just need for
export we either need an entrepreneur
that really knows how to make things
happen
or we need to maybe subcontract with
someone that's already in the export
business to move Eastern hay across the
ocean so those are just some of my
thoughts on it again I think there's
long term I think exporting hey there
the markets are gonna be there so that's
not a lot of data but a lot of thought
so as I Drive around my counties I see
this idle land and I the hardest part
like my said was getting people to get
the entrepreneurial spirit and thought
in their head to really make things
happen any questions for any of us
do you consider it when you're looking
at putting one is there any risk of
crime so is there a risk of degrading
the soils basically well you know when
we want to build our soils we usually
put them into forage so I think you know
forage is a great way to build soils and
maintain maintain and build soil quality
and prevent corrosion so I don't I guess
you know if you have shrubs like in my
my little 8 acre field I had to pull up
you know four inch pine trees and
honeysuckle bushes and so you know
there's a little bit of disturbance
there but it's a short-term disturbance
but I think that would be the only risk
there really
yeah I would just chime in and say again
kind of marginal and what you're doing
with it so I think most of these lands
better many of these things are not at
all suitable for annual production on an
ongoing basis but most of them are you
know biophysically suitable for
production but strikes me the biggest
problem
you mentioned the variable weather in
you know when you're going to harvest a
and the quality and it's so variable in
New York State and in the West they can
guarantee a quality for better way
irrigate it's hot you're in the Central
Valley you guarantee a quality to your
buyer here that's you know quite
difficult for an export market as I'm it
is I I think the West has an advantage
but I think I think if we really want
the two we could do it if we added maybe
a little bit more machinery maybe some
inoculants well this is why I was
thinking more of what Peter said you
know back to the something like the
pellets or something that maybe is not
as economic that that's much less
dependent on you know having good
quality forage it's more biomass and
fellas not that I'm in favor of it I'm
just trying to point out since this
seems like a really difficult thing for
someone to invest even the Westerners
come here they want to diversify but
then they say yeah but it's really hard
to make projections because the weather
is so variable here well so agreed and I
think you're right we wouldn't be doing
alfalfa but if you have Kentucky
bluegrass and Ladino clover and it rains
all week I'm just gonna leave it there
no the only thing that changes if some
leaves die and some new leaves grow so
the quality doesn't it's not like oh if
it was alfalfa for a whole week you'd be
gaining it like a percentage point of
NDF a day okay or a couple days so I
think if we if we think outside the box
a little bit
we're not gonna maybe be as competitive
as the West but I think we've got a I
think we can play with them
you know there was another question yet
try to formulate this into a question
just looking at the three conversations
here we have about somewhere north of
three billion dollars worth of assets
sitting out there not being used bigger
you know a million plus million acres
you have this industry which is
potentially profitable this evening if
you're anything in this tree but it's
just kind of not happening and you know
it has quite huge a critical mass or
industrial cluster or whatever wherever
it has to be and here we have all this
hay production and we're thinking about
exporting it when we have this enormous
market that's eating beef in New York
City is eating like a million v
panelists here so it's you know it seems
like hard to quite put this together and
explain it and maybe it's just an
economic development question maybe this
land really isn't profitable maybe it's
just like Bitcoin just some money in
that is it not virtual but it's a store
of value I mean that's not my sense my
sense is we can run profitable grazing
operations and get the land more
productive but negative in perennial
pasture but I guess the question then is
why is this the situation I mean what is
the solution is this is an economic
development job for for our government
or I can give you mine on Cooperative
Extension Aaron Gabriel point of view I
know we keep talking about feeding the
population in 2050 but honestly we have
way too much food around you know
there's the the real the real source of
this issue is markets you know if there
was a profitable efj market consistently
profit obese
market or a consistently profitable
Haymarket there wouldn't be any idle
land in New York or anywhere okay so
honestly we have an an overproduction in
our system and there's plenty of food I
know in some parts of the world it's not
but it's not a matter of supply it's a
matter of you know Civil War and all the
other sociological things that are going
on so so I mean I don't want to be
depressing you know but we have a lot of
food and there's it's hard to market it
so my neighbor has sold their dairy
animals right I just visited a farmer
yesterday who's gonna be selling his
animals in a couple months our holes a
health production system is is a
challenge a lot less and the market is a
lot closer the rest of the components of
the system are not here you know the low
cost processing the finishing their
human capital around the world even
though we have a lot of dairy people
it's really kind of two different
species actually so I don't know well I
agree with you because I just bought
grassland right I just bought grass-fed
hamburger in the store from Australia
and there actually is a group a guy he
spoke at our wintergreen up meeting him
and forgetting his name and the name of
his business but he's trying to get
farmers he's trying to get two types of
farmers cow-calf operations and
finishers do grass-fed beef here in the
Northeast you know and so I hope that
works but it's getting farmers to work
together it's getting that entrepreneur
that like this person and yourself
that's got the vision to actually make
it work so yes
transition it's um you I think you can
do it it's a totally different financial
structure though I would say you know
they're going from you know high-value
milk is pretty high value compared to
beef you know and you know 70 bucks a
head profit so if you want to make a
living you'd need a thousand cattle
right so the you know my neighbors I
think he had a herd of about a hundred
and fifty dairy cows he's got 300 acres
you know to go to a thousand head of
beef animals and then if every dairy
farmer did that you know what happens to
the markets so I mean I don't want to be
depressing it's really frustrating I've
been with extension for 23 years and I
started to I went into it to help
farmers and 23 years later is the very
same issue and I said what have I been
doing all this time this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu